[Musik]
was glaubt ihr wie viele menschen sind
in ihrem job glücklich wenn man
typischen aussagen beim smalltalk
glauben schenken will
dann sind es die meisten wohl eher nicht
der boss ist zu strengen das galt
natürlich zu niedrig die arbeit zu
langweilig und das wochenende kann nie
früh genug kommen
und tatsächlich waren laut in diesem
artikel im jahr 2009 90 prozent der
deutschen arbeitnehmer mit ihrem job
unzufrieden
eine vernichtende statistik umso
überraschender im jahre 2015 so das
institut der deutschen wirtschaft sind
aus diesem 90% beruflicher
unzufriedenheit angeblich 90 prozent
zufriedenheit geworden
was ist da passiert vielleicht haben ja
die entwicklungen des deutschen
arbeitsmarkt es tatsächlich dafür
gesorgt dass innerhalb von sechs jahren
eine komplette 180 grad wende
stattgefunden hat trotz all der burnout
diagnosen dem steigenden leistungsdruck
und der gefühlten bedrohung durch die
automation
vielleicht lässt sich dieser widerspruch
aber auch einfach damit erklären dass
der begriff glück für uns menschen zwar
ein extrem wichtiges aber auch eben ein
sehr abstraktes und vor allem
subjektives konzept ist also wollen wir
das feld einmal von hinten auf was ist
glück überhaupt und wie wird man
wissenschaftlich glücklich
von der aristotelischen philosophie bis
zur freud'schen psychologie das thema
glück hat für die menschheit schon immer
eine extrem große rolle gespielt so groß
dass das streben nach glück als
sinnstiftendes lebensziel und als
unantastbares persönlichkeitsrecht zum
beispiel in der declaration of
independence festgeschrieben wurde
aber wie genau fühlt sich glück
eigentlich an jeder von uns zumindest
hoffe ich das hat schon mal
glücksgefühle verspürte eine gute
schulnote ein hart erkämpfter sieg mit
der fußballmannschaft tolle
geburtstagsgeschenke oder das erste mal
verlieben
all das sind beispiele für dinge die
glück hervorrufen
allerdings sind wir der eigentlichen
emotionen dabei noch nicht näher
gekommen
deswegen habe ich euch mal auf twitter
und instagram gefragt wie ihr glück
definieren würde und wie man sieht glück
ist gar nicht mal so einfach zu fassen
vielleicht erstmal rein biologisch was
läuft da ab wenn man glücklich ist
allgemein gelten die glückshormone
endorphine und dopamin als die stoffe
die ausgeschüttet werden sobald wir uns
wohl fühlen
aber ganz so einfach ist es wie so
häufig nicht wenn wir über die mysterien
rund um unser gehirn sprechen
so ist auch glück noch nicht vollständig
entschlüsselt aber sicher scheint dass
tatsächlich ein bunter cocktail aus
verschiedensten hormonen und
neurotransmittern für unser glück
verantwortlich ist all diese botenstoffe
und ihre wechselwirkungen untereinander
sorgen dafür dass einerseits
empfindungen wie schmerz und stress
gehemmt und andererseits zuneigung
bindung und aktivität gesteigert werden
diese mischung aus entspannung und
stimulation funktioniert auch schon bei
der erfüllung der einfachsten
bedürfnisse wie hunger schlaf oder
unserem sexualtrieb ein prinzip das wir
mit anderen tieren teilen nicht umsonst
verwendet man in der regel futter oder
belohnende streicheleinheiten um zb
hunde zu konditionieren der vierbeiner
macht sitzt bekommt ein leckerli und
verbindet in zukunft das damit
einhergehende glücksgefühl mit dem
gelernten wenn wir menschen von gott
sprechen meinen wir allerdings in der
regel mehr als nur die kurzweilige
freude über etwas zum naschen was wir
den meisten aber nicht allen tieren
voraus haben ist dass wir in der zeit
voraus planen können und zb diese art
der momentanen gratifikation hinten
anstellen um vor allem langfristig und
nachhaltig ein glücklicheres leben zu
führen
die wirkungs faktoren die diesen
anhaltenden glückszustand beeinflussen
sind dabei mindestens genau so komplex
und individuell unterschiedlich wie der
begriff selbst
es gibt jedoch ein element das in der
forschung immer wieder als die
universelle glücks quelle schlechthin
auftaucht soziale bindungen
bei einer umfrage des time magazins zum
thema glück im leben nannten mehr als
die hälfte der 1000 teilnehmer innen die
familie im allgemeinen beziehungsweise
kinder oder enkel im speziellen als den
teil ihres lebens der ihn am meisten
glück beschert weitere elf prozent
nannten ihre religion und ihren partner
wir sehen also zwei von den drei größten
glücksbringern zumindest in den usa
haben mit zwischenmenschlichen
beziehungen zu tun
auch andere dinge die genannt wurden zum
beispiel das ausüben von hobbys hat in
vielen fällen indirekt damit zu tun dass
man sich mit gleichgesinnten umgibt und
sogar beim glück durch religionen lässt
sich darüber streiten welche rolle der
glaube an sich spielt und welche das
zusammenfinden und sich identifizieren
mit einer gemeinde wie menschen sind
soziale wesen dementsprechend streben
wir nach zuneigung gesellschaft und
vernetzung und sind nachweislich
glücklicher wenn wir diese dinge im
leben öfter erfahren andere dinge die
häufiger mit typischen eigenschaften
eines erfüllten lebens assoziiert werden
jugend intelligenz bildung oder äußere
umstände wie zb gutes wetter fallen laut
forschern weit weniger ins gewicht
allerdings gibt es einen zentralen
faktor in unserer gesellschaft bei dem
es ein klein wenig komplizierter ist und
das sind die moneten die scheine die
kohle
kurz gesagt das geld geld macht nicht
glücklich
diesen spruch kennt ihr mit sicherheit
vielleicht habt ihr schon mal selber
gesagt aber wie viel ist da dran
klar glück an sich ist keine ware die
wir aus dem regal nehmen können und uns
kaufen können und vieles von dem was uns
glücklich macht zum beispiel unsere
sozialen kontakte ist auch nicht
wirklich käuflich aber dennoch in einer
kapitalistisch geprägten kultur wie
unserer müsste uns da geld nicht
genügend möglichkeiten eröffnen etwas
für die erreichung unseres ganz
persönlichen glücks zu tun
unabhängig davon was man davon hält den
meisten wohl einleuchten dass jemand der
finanziell sorglos durchs leben geht im
zweifel glücklicher ist als jemand der
jeden cent zweimal umdrehen
während ein kaputter kühlschrank für
manche von uns nur einen grund zum
ärgern wäre stellte für andere eine
echte finanzielle bedrohung dar und sich
ab und zu auch mal einen
restaurantbesuch zu leisten und gute
küche genießen zu können das macht eben
auch mehr spaß als ich nur mit dem
nötigsten satz zu halten
viel interessanter ist aber ja die frage
gibt es eine grenze gibt es einen
emotionalen unterschied zwischen einem
restaurantbesuch für 20 euro und einem
für 200 kurz gesagt bedeutet mehr geld
auch mehr glück mit genau dieser frage
hat sich unter anderem der
wirtschaftswissenschaftler richard
easterlin in den 70er jahren beschäftigt
über 25 jahre hinweg beobachtet er
inwiefern ein höheres
bruttoinlandsprodukt eines landes mit
dem subjektiven glücksempfinden der
einwohner dieses landes korreliert
das ergebnis mag überraschen die stelen
kam zum ergebnis dass mehr geld nur so
lange auch mehr glück bedeutet bis alle
grundlegenden bedürfnisse gestillt sind
das ist das easterlin paradoxon
immerhin verfügen personen durch die
erfüllung dieser lebens voraussetzungen
überhaupt erstmal über die nötige
sorglosigkeit im alltag um die sonstige
erfüllung ihres glücks ins auge fassen
zu können wenn diese basis aber gegeben
ist dann scheint es so als seinen
menschen mit mehr geld nicht wesentlich
zufriedener als solche mit weniger
psychologen wie edward diener bestätigen
easterlin stunde
andere setzen den schwellenwert ein
wenig hörer an
laut dieser studie zum beispiel scheint
es ab einem jahreseinkommen von ca
68.000 euro keinen zusammenhang mehr zu
geben zwischen geld und glück und wenn
wir uns daran erinnern dass es vor allem
die zwischenmenschlichkeit ist die unser
glück maximiert dann kann man sich auch
vorstellen warum während mehr geld ein
bis zu einem bestimmten punkt vielleicht
dazu befähigt mehr zu unternehmen zu
erleben und dabei womöglich auch neue
bekanntschaften zu machen sind es über
diesen punkt hinaus zunehmend materielle
statussymbole die man sich von seinen
zusätzlichen millionen kaufen kann
ok geld ist also nicht völlig unwichtig
aber noch wichtiger scheint zu sein wie
man dieses geld bekommt wie wichtig ist
die arbeit für das glücks befinden
für viele ist der beruf sinnstiftend und
identität geben eine wichtige säule im
leben in unserer heutigen gesellschaft
sieht man nicht nur einen beruf aus mann
ist arzt oder man ist anwalt außerdem
verbringen wir hier unter der woche die
hälfte unserer machen
1 zeitarbeit gibt außerdem die
finanziellen mittel die wir zum leben
brauchen
und deswegen bestimmt sie zu großen
teilen wie wir den rest unseres lebens
gestalten
wo wohne ich wie flexibel kann ich mit
meiner freizeit umgehen und welchen
menschen und ideen begegnet sie ist
außerdem für viele die naheliegende
möglichkeit um das leben anderer positiv
zu beeinflussen
da ist es kein wunder dass die richtige
arbeit auch oft schon von klein auf ein
wunsch ist
kinder wollen astronautinnen oder
feuerwehrmänner werden persönlichkeit
und beruf scheinen oft untrennbar nicht
nur hip startups wie unseres hier in
köln sondern auch einige großkonzerne
haben inzwischen erkannt wie wichtig es
ist leben und arbeit miteinander zu
vereinbaren
die berühmte work life balance es
entstehen immer mehr moderne büro
konzepte die durch ihren besonderen
aufbau und pausen angebote
ausgeglichenheit und kreativität fördern
sollen kollaboratives arbeiten hat
inzwischen einen höheren stellenwert und
regelmäßige teambuilding events stärken
den zusammenhalt zwischen den kollegen
und die identifikation mit dem
unternehmen
einer der gründe warum das moderne
arbeiten hoffentlich auch zu mehr glück
führen wird
okay aber wie werde ich denn jetzt
wirklich wissenschaftlich glücklich nun
wie gesagt ist das streben nach glück
immer eine sehr subjektive angelegenheit
aber alles was ich gerade angesprochen
habe hilft uns dabei zumindest drei
konkrete bereiche festzulegen die für
die meisten menschen einen großen
unterschied machen können umgibt sich
mit menschen die du gerne hast und sei
dort ruhig etwas kritisch sei zufrieden
mit dem was du hast denn das hilft dir
den fokus auf das zu richten was du
wirklich brauchst und zu guter letzt
über einen beruf aus indem du dich
verwirklichen kannst und in dem dann
schaffen etwas positives in der welt
verändert
der beruf ist wie gesagt ein wichtiger
aspekt um glücklich zu werden
deswegen wurde das heutige video
unterstützt von der bundesagentur für
arbeit
und wie stellt vor ein selbst
erkundungstour das wissenschaftlich
fundiert dabei hilft gute
ausbildungsberufe studiengänge für dich
zu finden die hat zu dir passen dazu
gehen wir auf das bringt mich weiter
punkt de / typisch ich okay ich probiere
es einfach mal aus beruflicher vorlieben
bin ich eher der kreative oder der
handwerkliche typ sein arbeitgeber
möchte mit einem projekt für den
umweltschutz werden das projekt soll in
zwei arbeitsgruppen vorbereitet werden
die eine gruppe erstellt einen kurzfilm
über möglichkeiten die im alltag wasser
gespart werden kann
die andere gruppe analysiert proben und
neue wege der wasseraufbereitung zu
testen
ich würde natürlich mit filmen gehen
denn klappt fünf studiert jetzt in der
echten welt wobei proben analysieren es
auf der wissenschaftlich wird nicht
ehrlich gesagt auch interessieren
eine bank schreibt ein börsenspiel aus
an dem du mit einem team teilnimmst
erhältst du lieber zu jeder zeit und
haargenau in die kursschwankungen im
blick oder würdest du die rolle der
teamleitung übernehmen die die kauf- und
verkaufsentscheidungen steuert und ein
auge auf die konkurrenzteams hat für
mich muss alles seinen geregelten ablauf
haben ja sind schon ganz gut wenn man so
einen gewissen rhythmus hat ich würde
gerne mal im ausland leben leben weiß
ich nicht
wir haben zugegeben das ist ein bisschen
vorgespult das ergebnis könnt ihr unter
umständen nicht ganz so akkurat sein
aber jetzt durfte ich hier meine
ergebnisse sehen und meine top sechs
ausbildungsberufe ich bin schon sehr
gespannt
wir jäger gärtner tierpfleger im
tierheim und tierpension pferdewirt tier
wird oder fisch wird gehen wir aber
zurück und gehen einmal zu den studien
feldern
also ich hab mir um meine top sechs
studiengänge die quasi für mich
besonders gut passend sind die typisch
sind
aber da gibt es noch viel mehr dich mal
anschauen kann die ich da quasi dann zu
bestehen würde zum beispiel von den
fähigkeiten her welche anscheinend nicht
so gut im garten und landschaftsbau aber
von den sozialen kompetenzen schon eher
wo ich mir vielleicht schon vorher ohne
unabhängig von diesen tests nicht
angeguckt habe könnte ich jetzt quasi
nach gruppen wie gut würde ich dazu
wirklich passen und
wirtschaftsingenieurwesen fand ich mal
interessant aber dadurch dass ich total
wenig fähigkeiten diesem bereich habe
und dadurch dass ich auch nicht die
sozialen kompetenzen für diesen beruf
habe
wer das eventuell nicht so ein guter fit
für mich und ich sollte mir eventuell
überlegen ob ich mal was anderes als
studiengang aussuchen sollte wenig
gerade dabei seit die schule zu beenden
oder ihr seid vielleicht schon aus der
schule raus und ihr fragt euch was soll
ich mit meinem leben anfangen was soll
ich studieren welchen ausbildungsberuf
soll ich machen dann kann ich euch das
selbst erkundungstour nur empfehlen das
ist ziemlich ausführlich es ist
wissenschaftlich fundiert und von der
bundesagentur für arbeit und für euch
ein sehr guter start um mehr
herauszufinden wofür bin ich geeignet
und was interessiert mich eigentlich
alles den link dazu findet ihr unten in
der video beschreibung und ich hoffe
dass wir mit diesem tool dann einen
guten start in die karriere findet und
am ende berufe ergreift die euch
glücklich machen
das war von mir vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]